ah hello uh sorry it took me a minute
it's always interesting getting the
technology to work the way it should
work uh but I'm John Quackenbush from
the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and
Harvard School of Public Health and uh
it's my honor to be here tonight as part
of bioconference live uh this is my
second year presenting at bioconference
live and I'm really looking forward to
uh spending time with all of you tonight
I just want to remind you that there is
a question and answer
um
a place where you can type in questions
and at the end of the
at the end of the session I'll be
reading the questions and answers as
they go along so as things come up
please feel free to enter your questions
and I'll try to get to them before time
runs out all right so
um
thank you very much for all joining me I
don't know how many people are out there
but uh I hope there's more than just me
so what I want to do tonight is tell you
a little bit about some of the
approaches that we've been developing
really integrative approaches to network
modeling and biological processes
and what gets me really excited about
working in this area is just the fact
that we have access to unprecedented
quantities of data and as I started to
think about this I realized that this
really provides us with a tremendous
opportunity to do something
um really extraordinary and unique and I
started searching for quotes I like to
use quotes and the talks that I give to
sort of summarize
the things that I think are really
important about what I'm going to
presenting and I think this quote
summarizes it perfectly every revolution
in science from the copernican
heliocentric model to the rise of
statistical and quantum mechanics from
Darwin's theory of evolution and natural
selection to the theory of the gene has
been driven by one and only one thing
and that's access to data and um to be
honest when I looked for a quote I
couldn't find one so this is actually a
quote that I made up uh so you're free
to use it and if you use it enough then
I can actually use it it'll be a famous
quote this is my intellectual selfie but
uh I really think it speaks truth to
um the challenges and the opportunities
that are presented by access to data
because data allows us to challenge our
existing models to falsify them to find
holes in them and to develop new models
that we can use to try to model and
understand the universe so in biological
systems we've really had a tremendous
opportunity because of access to data
and what we've tried to do over time is
to use that data at least in the context
of bio medical research to really
address what I think is the life cycle
of human disease that what we'd like to
be able to do is to use genetic
information to predict disease risk we'd
like to be able to use the information
we have available to to do better job a
better job of early detection to be able
to stratify patients and eventually to
identify within disease subtypes
particular therapies that are most
efficacious for those patients and our
overall goal in doing this is to improve
outcomes and quality of life for those
patients so the work that we've been
doing over the years has largely been
driven by access to data from
Technologies like DNA arrays but what's
been extraordinarily exciting for me
is really over the last few years the
availability of much more comprehensive
genomic data and in fact integrated
types of genomic data from the same
samples that are available to
Technologies like DNA sequencing
Technologies of course this data is only
part of the entire picture we try to
take advantage of but it's really this
increased access to data that's allowed
us to be able to think differently about
a whole host of different problems and
this is really driven by the falling
cost of DNA sequencing if we look at
sequencing and sequencing technology
what we've seen is that when the first
human genome was sequenced in the year
2000 uh the time required to sequence of
genome was still on the order of months
it took teams of people around the world
and the estimated cost at the beginning
of 2000 was that sequencing a genome
would cost on the order of 100 million
dollars over the next few years the cost
started falling and dropping roughly by
a factor of two every 18 months and this
is what everybody calls falling at the
same rate as Moore's Law although
Moore's law says the number of
transiters transistors on a chip doubles
it every 18 months and it doesn't quite
make sense in the context of sequencing
what it really talks about though is a
twofold change in something in a
relatively small period of time in this
case a two-fold change in sequencing
cost every
um 18 months but then in 2007 and 2008
we had the introduction of new
sequencing technologies that second
generation or people like to say next
Generation but really that second
generation of sequencing Technologies
and we went through a phase where the
cost of sequencing was dropping by 33
percent per quarter and for me as a
scientist this was really phenomenal
because it promised that soon we would
have access to absolutely massive
quantities of data and to sort of put
this in perspective I always like to
think about my own life in 2009 the cost
of sequencing had fallen to about a
hundred thousand dollars and when I look
at that I used to think about this
seriously in the context of you know my
family and our health I always used to
say if my wife or son had a rare cancer
that was refractor to therapy I'd
mortgage or house and sequence their
genome today the cost of genome
sequencing is approaching a thousand
dollars which means that I can pay for
it on a credit card it's Fallen to the
point where it's not out of the question
for many people to have genomic
sequencing performed and for research
studies and clinical practices to begin
to collect genomic sequence data the
real question is what do we do with this
data and the other types of genomic data
that we can generate now so readily so
we have to think about some of the
challenges inherent in dealing with
these large-scale data sets or what
people like to call Big Data so if you
think about Big Data they're definitely
technological challenges and just
collecting it managing it storing it but
there are also challenges that go beyond
those technical challenges and the
national research Council here in the
U.S actually commissioned a report uh on
massive data analysis and the committee
on massive data analysis published a
very nice report in 2013 in which
they've looked at the challenges and
they said you know the challenges go
beyond just the technical aspects
although those are not to be ignored and
anybody like me is wrestled with
large-scale data sets knows that these
technical challenges are significant but
in fact one of the key elements in
meeting big data's challenge challenges
is the development of rigorous
quantitative and statistical methods
that what we have to do is take the data
we can collect now and put it into some
kind of rational context there's a
website that I absolutely love if you do
a Google search for spurious
correlations what you can do is on that
website look at the massive data that
they've collected and find things like
correlations between
the number of U.S spending on space
exploration and the number of deaths by
strangulation in bed sheets that with
enough data you can find correlations
that are absolutely meaningless but have
extremely high correlation coefficients
and what we have to think about is
moving beyond just simple correlation we
have to really think rigorously about
new ways of looking at this large scale
data and making sense of it
so if you start to think about this
um what the NRC committee uh
really understood was that we had to
start thinking about this whole question
of statistical inference how we take
these associations and turn them into
meaningful methods that allow us to
infer real relationships between
elements in the data and in order to do
that we really have to develop a new
statistical rigor that allows us to make
the leap from data to knowledge and to
really move from knowledge to
understanding that we have to develop
new approaches to dealing with
absolutely massive data so that if we
don't do that in fact we may draw
conclusions that are false and
potentially uh harmful
so as my my colleagues started to think
about this General problem what we
realize is that there are a number of
challenges that needed to be addressed
the first was the problem of
normalization or pre-processing and
detection of hot spots important
features in the data set that we want to
try to be able to identify and make
sense of and so we recognize we need
methods to compare measurements across
sources and to find those Salient
features
we've dealt with problems with
normalization in gene expression
analysis and it's been really
interesting to me to see the lessons
we've learned in arrays ignored once
again in rnac but in fact it's not just
important in sequencing based
Technologies if we put the same patient
in two MRI scanners next to each other
they're not going to give us exactly the
same image and while a trained
radiologist may be able to look in and
identify a tumor in both of those really
as we start to deal with radio graphic
data on thousands of patients we need
automated techniques that can compare
those find them and identify the
features in a robust and quantitative
way so pre-processing is an important
problem the second one is one of data
integration and again I think that's
something that all of us working in this
field have faced that it's not just
genomic data it's not just Imaging data
that may be environmental exposure data
it's clinical data it's phenotypic data
that in order to get the most out of any
individual data set we often have to add
even more we have to add external
sources of information that we can use
to build robust models or we have to add
multiple different types of measurements
on our samples in order to make sense of
them
the third piece that we identified as
being important is that of reproducible
research and what we really have to do
is leverage our ability to generate data
very rapidly in order to be able to
validate or invalidate the conclusions
that we draw from data and then finally
and a big part of what I want to talk
about in this presentation
is the need to develop new methods that
move
Beyond correlations and capture some of
the non-linear but very important
associations that we see as being
important in biological systems so I'm
going to briefly talk about each one of
these but I'm going to focus on on the
fourth Network methods so batch effects
and normalization as I mentioned there
are one of the things that we've spent
as a field I think a lot of time dealing
with and there's a really beautiful
paper published a few years ago by
Rafael rosari and some of his colleagues
looking at the widespread and critical
impact of batch effects and high
throughput data and what they did was
they looked at a number of large-scale
studies including many of the
measurements made in the cancer genome
Atlas and what they showed was that in
those large-scale data sets even if you
performed a pretty reasonable
normalization what you could do and you
can see this in the lower left hand
corner of the the slide is you can
actually Identify some genes in this
case that were different between
different batches different between
different Lots so even after normalizing
the data there are still residual
effects and that if you focused on those
effects you could actually separate the
samples based on where they were
collected and they showed in this paper
that in fact this was not an unusual
phenomenon that in almost every day
large scale data set they looked at they
could identify these batch effects and
while they suggested methods that might
work to eliminate them or reduce their
severity
they and I think we recognize that
there's still a lot of work to be done
to develop more robust methods to handle
these batch effects at scale
the second key point we identified was
integrative analysis and the need to
perform integrative analysis and in this
case it's really looking at the fact
that we can generate multiple different
types of data on our samples so these
new technologies these new sequencing
technologies have been absolutely
phenomenal for me as a scientist because
it allows me not just to look at one
aspect or one feature even of the
sequence based data we can look at the
genome and understand the genetic
background we can look at RNA sequencing
to measure gene expression levels we can
look at regulatory information from Chip
seek we can look at epigenomic data we
can look at proteomics data and each one
of these gives us a complementary view
on the biological processes that are
underway but the challenge is that what
we'd like to do is take not only those
but phenotypic data to Anchor our
measurements in the inference that we
draw from those measurements in order to
really a draw robust conclusions but as
we start to do that and in particular a
lot of work that we do in a clinical
setting we're dealing with data that's
not perfectly
captured in a way that we can use
effectively so if we look at electronic
medical records which everyone is very
excited about what you discover is that
those are designed not to capture
phenotypic data in a robust way they're
really administrative and billing
databases in that most of the
interesting data is in the notes fields
in fact just yesterday or today there
was a very nice story in the New York
Times talking about one of the
challenges with big data and that's data
wrangling or being a data janitor how
you take these imprecise data sets and
turn them into something that you can
actually use and use effectively but
once you do that you have to recognize
there are multiple hidden dependencies
in olmic data and other types of data
and that we have to identify those and
use them as we build our models so that
while we can constrain them using
multiple sources of data and information
we don't want to over constrain them and
we don't want to misidentify
correlations in the data based on
dependencies that we didn't know existed
um a third piece is that the need for
reproducible research and here I just
want to briefly mention the fact that
large-scale studies are not immune even
from very good groups are not immune to
challenges in effectively collecting
data so in December of last year uh my
colleagues and I published a paper in
nature describing the inconsistencies in
two large
very well done pharmacogenomic studies
they were this Cancer Center cancer cell
line encyclopedia from the broad
Institute and the cancer Genome Project
from the Massachusetts General Hospital
and the Sanger Institute and in both of
those studies what the groups did was a
gene expression analysis on a large
number of cell lines they also performed
pharmacogenomic screens and a large
number of compounds across all of those
cell lines so these are very challenging
measurements to make you have to make
hundreds of measurements with different
doses across thousands of many many cell
lines and well we looked at the data
what we hope to be able to do was to
build predictive models using one data
set and predict drug response on the
other data set as we did that we ran
into problems and so he started to ask
ourselves where those problems might
arise so we looked at the data there
were 471 cell lines that were in common
and unfortunately only 15 drugs but 15
drugs measured on 471 cell lines for the
phenotypic response that were shared
between the two studies well we looked
at this what we saw was the gene
expression measures were highly
concordant both within studies where
they had replicates in between studies
so we looked at the same cell line the
data were very highly correlated
so that gave us actually a lot of faith
in in the quality of these experiments
that I think really speaks to the
investment over many years
made by people in the field to refine
both the experimental procedures in the
analytical protocols we use for these
large-scale gene expression data sets on
the other hand when you look at the
phenotypic measures what we discovered
was the correlation between the
phenotypic measures and the two studies
was poor in almost every every one of
the 15 cases we looked at and I think a
big part of the reason for that is just
the experimental challenge in trying to
fit a sigmoidal response curve to
predict the response to increasing doses
of these shrubs but to do it scale where
you don't want to give the cell lines
doses that are so high all the cells die
and to do it at scale what typically is
done is the doses are given our very low
doses are given and then one tries to
estimate the response and I think the
problem is that those protocols aren't
really well standardized so we looked at
these two studies the correlation was
poor when we looked at a third study the
correlation and the phenotypic measures
there was also poor and when we try to
deconvolute Y what we showed what we
discovered was that the third study was
actually slightly closer to the one that
used the a more similar protocol which
probably isn't surprising but there was
no way to really see which of the
studies was right which is something the
referees and the editors asked us to do
and all we could do is say well what
this really means is that uh as a field
we have to go back and look more
carefully at the applications of these
Technologies and really focus on these
fundamental questions of standardization
and reproducibility and normalization
so if you think about an old Mac
biomarker it's really a feature set
and an algorithm and what we have to do
is recognize that in building these
predictive biomarkers we have to be very
careful in putting these things together
that we have to do a robust job of
separating those features which
distinguish phenotypes we also have to
carefully select algorithms that we use
in order to be able to make predictions
that ultimately are going to tell us
about the biological systems we're
studying
right so I've talked about three of the
areas that big data enables but what I
most wanted to talk about today is this
whole question of estimating Gene
regulatory networks or using biological
information and synthesizing it from
multiple different measurements to make
sense of the systems that we're studying
and I'm going to talk about work at
least initially that I've done largely
with my colleague gcum and Kimberly
glass who was a postdoctoral fellow
working with us she's now a new
assistant professor continuing to
collaborate with both of us at Harvard
Medical School
so we started to think about Network
some time ago and for a number of years
my group and I have been looking at
different ways to estimate networks from
biological systems and one of the things
that I always found challenging when we
submitted papers was referees would
write back and they would say well how
do we know the network is right
and when you really push on the referees
what we often discovered was that they
wanted us to be able to say well this
network looks like a network that
appears in a textbook
and as we started to look at this
question we realized that that probably
didn't make sense that if we think about
a normal
um state of a cell well we might talk
about sort of the canonical Network for
that state that in fact as we move
beyond that what we could start to see
is the network structure changes and
changes in different disease States now
if you think about that that actually
makes perfect sense we can have
connections that drop out because one
gene is no longer expressed or because
it's mutated in a way that it can no
longer interact with some other Gene but
in fact it can be mutated or expressed
in a particular fashion that allows you
to create new connections so that part
of the difference in the phenotypes we
observe can really be driven by
differences in the network topologies
and so that if we look at even two
different states of a disease what we
may find and what we ultimately are
probably interested in are the changes
in that underlying Network in the
network topology so we've really started
to think about this and try to think
about how we might model systems produce
models of systems that would tell us
something about those underlying
networks and how they evolve given
changes in phenotype
the the question that GC and uh kimby
and I decided to look at and they
discusses quite a bit in collaboration
with Curtis huttenhauer was the problem
of regulation of transcription
now what we know about transcriptional
events is that in order for a DNA
message to be our DNA that Gene to be
turned into a protein that Gene first
has to be transcribed into RNA in order
for that to happen we have to have an
RNA polymerase bind to the DNA and as
you probably know that process is
facilitated by The Binding of multiple
transcription factors to the surrounding
region to the region surrounding a gene
so that those transcription factors
actually facilitate the recruitment of
the RNA polymerase and the creation of
an RNA transcript
so as we started to look at this and
really think about it what we came to
recognize was that in some way we could
model this as a process of communication
that we have transcription factors and
those transcription factors are
communicating
Downstream to their target genes they're
sending a message to that Gene that says
turn on
and in discussing this problem what we
realized was that there's a whole
literature about modeling Transmission
in networks and communication and
networks and it's an idea in
Communications Theory that's called
Affinity propagation or message passing
now the way this works is that when we
think about both the transcription
factor and its Target we realize that
both of them have to be actively
participating in the communication for
information to flow right a radio
transmitter is transmitting but if your
radio is turned off no information is
going to flow into your um into your
radio on the other hand if you turn on
the radio and the transmitter is down no
information flows right so what we can
do is we can model this process by
assuming that there's a mathematical
function we call the responsibility
associated with the transcription factor
with the transmitter it's responsible
for communicating with this target but
the target has to be available the
analogy I like to use is that often I'll
come home from work and I'll walk in the
door I'll take off my shoes and as I'm
setting my things down my wife is eager
to talk to me and she starts telling me
about her day and unfortunately when
when she starts as soon as I walk in the
door I almost never hear what she's
saying because I'm starting to put all
the pieces together and think about
what's going on so I may catch part of
it but I may not catch all of it and
later she'll say well don't you remember
I told you this and I'll I'll look at
her and I'll say uh with all honesty you
didn't tell me and she'll say yes I did
and of course being a husband I know I'm
wrong but in truth without an outside
Observer there's no simple way of
knowing where Communications is broken
down as she felt to tell me or is I have
I failed to hear it so what we can start
to do is try to estimate these functions
by looking at correlations in their
activation because if both
at the transmitter and receiver are
active in a similar way then we can
understand that information is falling
but if it's not well we have to rely on
is the fact that we have a more complex
Network so that if communication flows
through one channel but not another we
can understand whether communication is
broken down either the transmitter or at
one or more of the receivers so if I
tell all you about this and you all
understand it perfectly then we've all
done our job
if I tell you about message passing and
nobody understands anything then I
failed in transmitting but if some of
you understand it well and some of you
don't then we can actually model that by
taking the network of all possible
channels of communication and trimming
it to reflect what information is really
flowed so that's what we want to try to
be able to do and so we've been using
this method that we developed called
Panda and what Panda does is exactly
what I described it takes it uses the
fact that we've sequenced The genome and
we have extensive databases of
transcription Factor motifs we know
where those transcription factors bind
and so we can build a preliminary
Network essentially representing all
possible channels of communication but
what we do then is we take other sources
of data in the case of the first
implementation of panda gene expression
data and protein protein interaction
data and we use those then for each Edge
in the network to estimate the
responsibility and availability what
that allows us to do is then to update
the network model and then we iterate
the process until we converge on a
network that we believe best represents
the state of the network given the data
so what we've tried to do is apply that
in a number of different situations and
I'm going to tell you about one example
this is actually a comparison of two
subtypes of ovarian cancer
if you're familiar with the cancer
genome Atlas they identify a number of
other subtypes and I can tell you that
we've analyzed those subtypes as well
and we're looking at incorporating
additional data types in our analysis of
those subtypes but the first application
we had was a simple application just
comparing two subtypes and these two
subtypes were described in a 2009 paper
that we published in which we found
there were differences in gene
expression and that those differences
were driven by genes associated with
angiogenic processes so when we looked
at these These are actually clinically
relevant subtypes I apologize in the
lower right hand car lower left hand
corner it may be difficult to see the
differences in survival but the smaller
subgroup the group expressing and
eugenesis genes probably not
surprisingly has poor outcome than the
larger non-angiogenic subtype and then
in fact in the paper what we did was
compared multiple different data sets
including data from the cancer genome
Atlas and found that across those data
sets 11 different data sets representing
well over a thousand patients that there
were differences in survival for those
patients who had this angiogenic
phenotype or at least we're expressing
the angiogenic genes so what we decided
to do was to use Panda to test what the
differences were in those networks so we
took all the gene expression data we
didn't take a selected subset of genes
we took all of the data that were
available and we had two subsets one
representing the antigenic subtype which
will always be displayed in red and the
non-angiogenic subtype always displayed
in blue and what we did was he took our
Motif data we took protein protein
interaction data from public resources
we took that gene expression data and we
built networks for those two and then we
asked ourselves how do these networks
compare to each other
as we did that what we really focused on
were differences in these connections
right that that little anecdote I told
you earlier about looking at differences
in the networks by looking at
differences in the edges really came
back to us as we started to look at
comparing the networks in the angiogenic
and non-angiogenic subtypes and that
what we started to realize was the atom
of the network what made one network
distinct and different from another that
individual unit
was not the genes but the edges the
connections and that those connections
were fundamentally important and in a
lot of ways whenever I say this now it
seems obvious to me but at the time it
was a real Revelation so we're very
excited to see this and what we started
to do was construct networks and so
these are the two networks of the
angiogenic and non-angiogenic subtype
this is the angiogenic network this is
the non-angiogenic network you probably
can't see very much in looking at these
but what we're able to do was actually
identify 10 key transcription factors
and we picked these transcription
factors not because we knew they had
anything to do with angiogenesis but in
fact because these were the
transcription factors that seemed based
on our modeling as transmitters to
switch their activities more completely
more thoroughly more profoundly between
the two different subtypes so when we
looked at these we did the first thing
everybody does which is look to see
whether or not we can tell a story based
on things that are in PubMed and a
former postdog and colleague of mine
Stefan bentig always described this as
the process of Bio poetry right that you
take the genes and you tell a beautiful
story so in fact for every Gene that we
found we could tell a story about
angiogenesis
but for me that's not necessarily very
convincing uh because we could probably
have done that with any other random set
of 10 genes so what we started to do was
to look at the patterns of different a
differential expression both for the
transcription factors and for their
Downstream targets and we started to see
something very interesting what we
observed was that in many instances that
transcription factors themselves were
not differentially expressed but their
targets were
so what that suggested to us is that
what we were seeing was actually a
change in the transcriptional networks
that the topology of the network was
starting to change and the transcription
factors themselves weren't varying we
couldn't have found them in a normal
differential expression analysis but
they seem to be targeting different
things and that in fact when we looked
at patterns of other data like DNA
methylation data they seem to correlate
with what we're observing in looking at
the genes themselves that the
transcription factors didn't seem to
undergo profound differences in
methylation but some of their Downstream
targets did and in a way that made sense
given what we were observing in the
expression of those Downstream targets
so we started to look at this and to
really think about the patterns of Gene
activation that we saw what we saw were
genes which we called A Plus or a minus
and these were genes that seemed to be
only targeted in one subtype the
angiogenic subtype and either had their
expression increase or decrease because
we know transcription factors can be
activating well pressing
so we identified those we identified
other Trends other genes that seemed
only to be targeted in the
non-angiogenic subtype and again those
were either going up or going down but
then we found classes of genes that
actually seem to be targeted in both
but often had different patterns of
expression between those so we call them
A Plus n minus or n plus a minus
depending on whether they were up or
down and the angiogenic or
non-angiogenic subtypes well we've
looked at those what we started to see
was that in fact each class of genes
that we identified could be linked in a
very simple way by looking at
overrepresentation of go terms the
biological processes that are known to
be associated with driving or inhibiting
angiogenesis
so uh kimbi actually came up with a very
nice way of representing this data we
always call it the spirograph so if
you're old enough to remember this toy
when you were a kid you could draw these
neat spirals but really if you look at
this I think it's a nice way of
representing data because what you can
see if you look sort of at the lower
left hand corner of the spirograph is
that they're genes which are only
targeted by in this case the
non-angiogenic subtype you can find
genes that are only targeted in the
angiogenic subtype but what you start to
see are complex patterns of Regulation
where genes are targeted
by two or more of these 10 key
transcription factors
so what we did was we started to look at
those and what we discovered was that
the number of pairs of transcription
factors that we're targeting a gene were
far far greater than we would have
expected by chance
so again we started to think about this
combinatorial this problem of
combinatorial Regulation and one of the
things we came to realize was that this
these patterns of Regulation might in
fact be informative
and so we started to think about those
and the way in which different sets of
interacting transcription factors
interact to stimulate the expression of
genes and one of the very interesting
things we saw was there are actually
drugs that can interfere with the
dimerization of transcription factors or
change the methylation state of the
genome that are known to interfere with
angiogenesis
so our model which is based on comparing
two sets of genome-wide expression
profiles led us to identify therapeutic
interventions that are supported in the
literature but that really come from
looking at the network interactions in
these models so we try to find Direct
experimental evidence to support this
unfortunately we couldn't find any of
these compounds that had been applied in
ovarian cancer cell lines but one of the
interesting things we found was an
angiogenesis inhibitor that was used in
a breast cancer cell line and what we
found was exactly the pattern of gene
expression that we would have predicted
based on our model looking at these
different classes of
regulated genes so while we haven't yet
been able to fully experimentally
validate these findings what we found is
a great deal of supporting evidence that
suggests that these models are capturing
an essential feature that tells us
something about how regulation of genes
is associated with phenotype and it's a
model that's derived by really
integrating and synthesizing multiple
types of data so we're very excited
about the potential and where we think
this can go
the second type of analysis though that
I want to take some time and tell you
about and this is where really focused
on integrating two different types of
data so what we want to do is we want to
look at expressed quantitative trait
loci or the association between genomic
variance and gene expression so each ETL
analysis is actually based on an older
type of genomic analysis called GTL
analysis or quantitative trait Locus
analysis it was first developed actually
in agriculture looking at selective
breeding marker assisted breeding and
tomatoes and what the developers were
trying to do was find genetic markers
that were associated with quantitative
traits so that each one of the markers
could in some way influence the traits
and that a collection of the appropriate
markers would actually cause traits like
tomato color or fruit size or water
content to vary and that by identifying
those traits one could select
Offspring from crosses or direct crosses
we would try to improve those traits so
it was about 10 years 11 years ago that
a group I think largely led by Eric shat
started to think about how one might
look at gene expression as a
quantitative trait and so in each utl is
simply looking at measured expression
values as a quantitative trait that we
hope to be able to associate with a set
of genetic markers so what we wanted to
do was to use not one data set but again
in more than one in this case two data
sets collected on the same samples so we
wanted to look at genome-wide snip data
and gene expression data together and
we're going to treat gene expression as
a quantitative trait really asking which
Snips which genetic variants are
correlated with the degree of gene
expression
so
in the analysis uh this type of analysis
what most people have concentrated on
are CIS acting Snips Snips in the genome
that are close to the gene that they
regulate and a big part of the reason
for the focus on CIS acting Snips is
that these are the ones that can be
tested easily in an experimental setting
that what one might be able to do is to
modify say a transcription Factor
binding site associated with this net
and look at the downstream effects but
we recognize they're also transacting
Snips Snips that are acting at a great
distance even on different chromosomes
in the genome that somehow regulate gene
expression and you can begin to
hypothetize hypothesize a whole host of
different mechanisms by which those
interactions can occur
but we were simply looking for that
statistical association between snips
and this quantitative creatine gene
expression so
what we decided to try to do was to
really look at these eqtls in a slightly
different way that what we should look
for are snips
that regulate biological processes we
should have groups of snips and groups
of genes that somehow interact with each
other to regulate functions in the cell
that in complex traits it probably
wasn't enough simply to look at a family
of snips regulating a single Gene but
that there was some kind of association
between them and that's what we thought
we might be able to find
so we did a fairly standard eqtl
analysis in fact the first eqtl analysis
we ran was using plank to widely used
freely available software tool and what
we did was we looked for that
association between Snips and genes so
we started to ask ourselves
how are snips
associated with the expression levels of
these individual genes and what can we
say about them or more importantly can a
network of snip Gene associations
tell us something important about the
functional role of these Snips and
really that's what we're trying to get
at could we identify Snips that have
been found through genome-wide
Association studies for which there was
no clear mechanism
and tie them to some mechanism that we
could begin to use to understand disease
processes
so this idea germinated for a while and
then John platted who studied Network
physics as part of his PhD came to work
with me at Dana Farber and what we
decided to do was to think about the
association between genes and Snips and
the networks that we could build by
running well-established software tools
like plink to look at those networks and
actually think about those networks in a
different way to treat them as bipartite
graphs and a bipartite graph is a pretty
simple idea a pretty simple way of
representing complex relationships so
what we can think about in a bipartite
graph is we simply have two types of
nodes two types of objects that are
connected together in the case of the
slide we have circles and we have
squares and in our representation here
the squares are Snips and the circles
are genes so the only way I would
potentially modify this diagram would be
to draw arrows going from the Snips to
the genes because those Snips are
regulating the genes in our model not
the other way around
so if we build a model like that
can we start to tease apart
some of these groups some of these
associations
so we first said well if we build this
model what does the model look like and
so we started to think about the
structure of networks and for those of
you who have studied networks one of the
key features that everyone looks at in
networks are the nodes and one of the
things we've all come to sort of believe
is part of the law is that networks in
biological systems naturally occurring
networks should at least be consistent
with a power Lot distribution right that
we should have this scale free property
this if we make a log log plot of the
density of connections or the degree
distribution that what we should see is
something that looks roughly like this
so we took data from a project that
we've been involved with the lung
genomics research Consortium or lgrc
this was a large Consortium in which
there were over 1 400 samples that had
been collected at the Mayo Clinic those
samples were provided to um as part of a
study called the lung tissue research
Consortium they were provided to us as
part of the long genomics research
Consortium and they had multiple
different genomic assays run on the same
samples so we had genome-wide snip
profiles but we also had genome-wide
expression profiles so what we did was
we looked at the networks and what we
found in this model of chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease or COPD
that the the Snips the genes and the
combined Network had this kind of log
linear
kind of linear relationship on a log log
graph that people associate with these
scale-free networks or what John more
properly has told me is called a fat
tail distribution so that when we look
at the network what most people focus on
is down in the lower right hand corner
it's that collection of Highly connected
Snips highly connected elements that
have many many connections within that
Network itself
and so our first hypothesis in looking
at this network was that that might be
these that might be the area in which
we'd find uh disease-associated genes
excuse me disease-associated Snips so
when we started to look at the the tail
end of this distribution and search for
Snips that had been found through gy
studies or have been cataloged in the
nih-g loss catalog what we found was
that rather than being enriched for
Snips that area of the distribution was
actually depleted for snips so we went
back and started to think about the the
network and the structure of the
underlying networks and what that might
tell us all right so this raises a
second sort of important issue in our
thinking about biological networks and
that's how the networks themselves are
physically constructed
and the analogy I like to use here is if
you think about the cell phone network
right all of you are in principle
connected to everyone else in the world
everybody out there with a cell phone in
principle can call me they can send me
text messages they can reach out to me
in practice almost none of you do so I
don't know who's actually listening in
somebody maybe one of my friends who
calls me but most of you are probably
not one of my contacts one of the people
I'm in contact in a regular day and so
if you think about it you actually have
a network that that Network that
Community is defined by a group of
people who you call who are more likely
to call each other
and to call you than they are to call me
right so it's that interconnectivity in
your own social network your own social
group that defines your community
and if you're like me you probably have
a work Community right a weekday
community and a friends and family
weekend community
and in fact by looking at the structure
of the community any instant in time I
could probably predict whether it's a
weekend or a weekday Where You Are
so that structure of the network the way
the network is put together is actually
very important for understanding the
state of the system
and so the idea that John and I started
kicking around was that one might be
able to look at this network and
actually look at its community structure
so I mentioned John has a background in
network physics he actually did his PhD
with Michelle girvin Michelle is one of
the experts world's experts in community
structuring networks and there are a
whole host of community structure
algorithms that have been developed over
the years and essentially what they do
is they look for subsets in the network
where the connectivity within that
subset is much stronger than it is to
other elements of the network
so what one can do is actually to find a
metric for identifying communities and
as I mentioned there are a number of
algorithms that do that
and then begin to look for the
definition of those communities
so there are actually challenges in
doing this there's statistical
challenges in dealing large networks and
there are also challenges in dealing
with bipartite networks and really
coming up with a good model for
estimating whether the number of
connections are greater than what one
would expect by chance if you begin to
work through these though what you
discover
is that there are actually communities
Within These networks they're groups of
genes and groups of snips that are more
highly connected to each other
than they are to the rest of the network
and again this really sort of speaks to
my intuition about how networks might
work and how biological systems work
that well we can think of a few single
genetic variants that are strongly
associated with phenotype in fact
probably what we have are families of
snips that are co-regulating right or
somehow conspiring to regulate or
cooperating to regulate
families of genes
so you can ask if we look at these
different communities we find in our
networks are the over-represented for
different biological processes the
answer is using simple go term analysis
yes
and as you start to look at the
different communities you find that the
different communities represent
different processes and in the case of
looking at COPD these are different
biological processes that in fact make
sense in the context of understanding
the development progression of the
disease
so as we started to work through our
thinking about the overall problem of
looking at networks and looking at the
connection between Snips and genes we
came back to this question of where the
disease Snips are located and what John
started to do was to look at the local
connectivity because if we think about
hubs maybe it's not the Global Hub maybe
it's the local hub
the snip that perturbs a process
that's most important and so we started
to ask ourselves how does this local
connectivity tell us about the
likelihood of identifying
disease-associated Snips and what we've
discovered is that this community
structure is actually important
we ask ourselves are the disease gets
skewed towards the top of the list the
most highly connected Snips and the
answer is no that those highly connected
Snips at the tail of that distribution
are almost devoid of
disease-associated snaps that in fact
I would guess that those highly
connected Snips are selected against
being disease Associated because if you
think about if I have a snip that's
connected to lots of different processes
across the genome if that snip is highly
deleterious then chances are it would be
selected against
on the other hand if you look at the
communities and ask are the highly
connected Snips within the communities
associated with disease
the answer is yes that in fact depending
on what statistical test you use there's
a level of significance but every test
we've used has told us
that those highly connected local snips
are the ones that are most likely to be
disease Associated and again that speaks
to your intuition because what we're
starting to think about is that it's not
a snip disrupting a gene it's one or
more Snips disrupting a process and that
diseases develop not when the whole cell
falls apart
but when specific processes are
disrupted in very specific ways
so if you think about this by
integrating different sources of data
and creating a net worth model what
we've been able to do is actually start
to identify potential disease
associations for large numbers of snips
many of which have been found in gy
studies as being weakly associated with
disease so for us this is a really
exciting potential new discovery about a
method that can shed light on
interesting biological processes so I
open with a quote now I'll close with
two quotes these from real thinkers not
me the first is one of my favorites is
from William Gibson a science fiction
author he said the future is here it's
just not widely distributed yet so
hopefully if you believe this is the
future it's now a little bit more
broadly distributed and the second is
one of my favorites this is actually
from Enrico Fermi those of you who know
me know I did a PhD in physics and so I
always like to say that physicists are
the smartest people
but this is a quote from firming and
Fermi said before I came here I was
confused about this subject after
listening to your lecture I'm still
confused that at a higher level so I
want to thank you all I really wanted to
try to wrap up a few minutes before the
end because I know people have other
things in their other presentations but
in a few remaining minutes for those of
you who want to stay around I'll be
happy to answer questions
so
thank you very much and now I'll begin
to look through the questions all right
so the first question can the panda
method be used for more than true groups
and the answer to that question is
absolutely yes one of the things we've
been very happy about with panda is that
what